they were supposed to stop conflict in
eastern ukraine but the minsk agreements
have been repeatedly violated since
2015. with the threat of a russian
invasion can the accord still provide a
path to peace
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum political leaders and
diplomats say they're working hard to
prevent a russian invasion of ukraine
the so-called minsk agreements keep
coming up in their discussions they were
signed in belarus to try and secure a
ceasefire between ukrainian government
forces and russian-backed separatists in
eastern ukraine
the first version in 2014 failed to take
hold so a second accord called minsk 2
was signed the following year but both
sides accuse each other of breaking the
agreement at least 14 000 people have
been killed in fighting during the past
eight years
monitors from the organization for
security and cooperation in europe or
osce have reported hundreds of ceasefire
violations a day
despite this many diplomats insist the
minsk agreements are the only way
forward to secure peace
the minsk agreements remain the only
framework endorsed by this council in
resolution 20 20 uh 2202
for a negotiated peaceful settlement of
the conflict in eastern
ukraine kiev doesn't comply with the
minsk agreements refuses to establish a
direct dialogue with donetsk and luhansk
undermines the agreements to introduce
changes in the constitution the
exclusive statute of donbass local
elections and the amnesty all key issues
of the minsk agreements
regarding the possible recognition of
the so-called donetsk and the people's
republics by the russian duma i would
like to remind once again of the
ukrainian position which has never
changed if recognition is approved
russia will exit the minsk agreement's
de facto and according to the law as
well with all the consequences to come
the minsk 2 agreement contains 13 points
nine are designed to end the armed
conflict in ukraine while the other four
address the political impasse between
kiev and the pro-russia rebels
the agreement calls for the removal of
heavy weapons hostage exchanges release
of political prisoners and the pull out
of all foreign armed groups
it also sets a road map for political
dialogue this includes giving the
donetsk and luhansk region some devolved
powers and holding elections there but
russia wants special status for the
regions before returning the border to
kiev's control
russia maintains it was only a
facilitator and not part of the conflict
inside ukraine so it is not bound by the
terms of the agreement
all right let's bring in our guests in
moscow andre cortonov director general
of the russian international affairs
council
in kiev mikhailov venetsky associate
professor of sociology at national
university of kiev kiev mahila academy
in istanbul matthew bryza senior fellow
at the atlanta council and former
national security council official at
the white house a warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story michael let me
start with you why haven't the minsk
agreements worked and what are the
problems inherent in them
well there's one very simple thing that
is in the minsk agreements that was
agreed to in the first minsk and the
second minutes that russian troops must
leave ukrainian soil simple as that
until such time as russian troops have
not left ukrainian soil there is very
little to talk about with respect to
minsk
uh there's a requirement for local
elections there's a requirement for
changing the constitution etc but none
of that can be done until such time as
that territory is occupied by russian
forces and today to talk about minsk is
quite frankly completely i mean
ludicrous because we have uh almost 200
000 troops on our borders expected to be
uh invading the rest of ukraine any time
soon so i mean
quite frankly minsk is well effectively
dead and uh and it was put it was
basically killed by the kremlin uh by
not
uh when it when it basically
well decided to ignore the basics of the
uh of the agreement and that was to uh
to withdraw russian troops
uh andre by by most accounts uh the
minsk agreements um essentially were
dead on arrival they have not worked
from your perspective can they be
reworked
can they be modified in a way that the
process would work going forward and if
so how
well i think that realistically we
should probably focus on the so-called
military package within the misc
agreements which implies the first three
points of the agreements signed seven
years ago first of all stable and
verifiable ceasefire
second with the role of heavy weapons
and third that strengthen oec monitoring
missions in donbass
if we we're able to comply with the
first three points of the minsk
agreements that would already be a very
significant progress later on we can
move to the political agenda which will
probably have to be modified or updated
but of course that would require consent
of all those who signed the initial
agreements
matthew there are a lot of diplomats
right now that are saying the minsk
agreements are really the only path
forward when it comes to trying to
de-escalate this crisis when it comes to
the united states they've had very
little involvement in this process how
much can the u.s get involved now
well probably can't get involved
directly in the mints group negotiations
because
at least uh russia france and germany
who are the ones that kind of you know
were the with the leaders along with
ukraine or the participants uh they
don't want the u.s to participate i
think ukraine would love the us to be
involved in the negotiations but there's
not a direct role for the united states
but of course there's a huge indirect
role for the united states first and
foremost by rallying nato and
maintaining its solidarity right now in
an attempt to deter
uh
further russian use of military force
against ukraine and it's important to
know that
this threat by russia to use force is a
negotiating tactic
it may be a genuine threat to reinvade
ukraine as well
but it's a negotiation it's a piece of
negotiating leverage a very important
piece the goal however of russia i think
is not really to get the minsk
agreements uh finalized but of course
russia's objectives as articulated by
president putin are much broader than
the minsk agreement and they all have to
do with pushing back nato into its
pre-1997 borders
mikhail it looked earlier like you
wanted to jump in i'm going to let you
do that but i also want to ask you are
officials in kiev worried that the west
is going to try to use this russian
threat to strong-arm ukraine into
accepting moscow's version of the minsk
agreements
okay well i want to say three things
that i'm going to be very brief about
first of all people in ukraine are and
officials in ukraine are worried about
being invaded uh the west at the moment
is helping us uh and we are very
grateful for the military economic and
political aid diplomatic aid that is
being provided and quite frankly one of
the reasons that putin has not invaded
the country uh on mass yet has to do
with the fact that there is western
support so
quite frankly we're not concerned about
uh the west somehow uh leaving us dry
with this minsk agreement
uh at the end of the day uh everybody is
working towards avoiding a further
invasion my uh the other thing that i
wanted to say was to my american
colleague quite frankly that the
the goal of putin is to try to stop nato
etc putin has made it very clear as to
what he wants uh the whole nato thing is
quite frankly just a a
i mean
it's a diversion at the end of the day
putin wants to control ukraine putin
wants to re-uh re-establish greater
russia he is the gatherer of the russian
lands this is what he's about and
ukraine is something that is an absolute
requirement trotsky a hundred years ago
said that russia cannot exist without
ukraine and that is something that has
continued to be an ex
something that is in the russian mind in
the in the russian elite political
agenda for the last 30 years and quite
frankly uh today is or now is the time
according to putin to try to make that
dream a reality finally with respect to
the minsk agreements we need to
understand that these agreements were
signed when putin was holding a gun to
ukraine's head uh the first agreement
was signed uh after he bar after he was
bombarding mariupol uh the second
agreement was signed after there was
there were russian troops on the ground
in ukraine uh in a place called de
baltimo uh in both cases the goal was to
create a cease fire that ceased fire has
held basically plus or minus has held
for the last five or six years there's
been a line of contact and that line of
contact has had minimal firing across uh
shooting on either side during the last
day we've had over 100
uh ceasefire violations and those
ceasefire violations have all come from
the russian side at the end of the day
ukraine's demand is very simple russians
get out of our territory
matthew you were reacting there to some
of what mikhail was saying i'm going to
let you jump in
yeah i know i totally agree i mean i
agree with everything that mikhail said
and you know of course ukraine is the
immediate huge focus of what putin's
trying to do but there is this broader
geostrategic objective as well when
putin talks about the desire for a whole
new european security architecture which
which i think is is going to end up
being a proposal that's dead on arrival
but as far as debauchery goes that's a
very important example uh immediately
after minsk two was signed uh the
russians mounted a major assault on de
balsava in total violation of the first
aspect of the minsk uh second minsk
agreement which was a ceasefire as well
as the first uh minsk agreement which
was a ceasefire so from the beginning
russia has not observed the minsk
agreements uh in the contrary as mikhail
said it has kept its military forces in
ukraine on its territory even if it
denies that they're there uh it has
allowed uh the illegal armed formations
of the of the donetsk region to remain
in place those were supposed to be uh
disbanded and far from moving heavy
military equipment out of donbass russia
has massed up to 190 000 troops with
heavy equipment near the border so when
russia demands that ukraine comes into
compliance uh with the minsk agreements
well a it's it's not in compliance and b
um if it's threat to use military force
is supposedly to bring ukraine into
compliance well then it doesn't make any
sense that russia still claims not to be
a party to those agreements or the
conflicts why would you threaten to
invade a country uh to enforce an
agreement that you claim you're not a
party of
andre earlier this month there were
talks between ukrainian and russian
officials in the normandy format but
they really failed to make a
breakthrough correct
that's right that's right there was
disappointment expressed by mr kozak who
is a special envoy
uh of president putin he argued that he
failed to get any flexibility on the
ukrainian side in terms of the ukrainian
compliance with the minsk agreements
and do you think that there will be
further talks going forward
well i think that if indeed
the diplomatic path is something that
they would prefer
in the kremlin this is the only way to
go
it seems that
my core panelists from the united states
and ukraine
know much better than i do what putin
really wants and what he's up to
unfortunately i don't have such great
contacts in the kremlin to make sure
that the invasion is imminent and that
is likely to happen anytime soon
however i would suggest that
it's not really logical for putin to
launch a major military operation in
ukraine uh it's a lot that russia can
lose it's not much that russia can gain
i think uh it's in the interests of the
kremlin to preserve the pressure on
ukraine
and to insist on the full compliance of
the minsk agreements as they were signed
seven years ago
i think that this is the ultimate goal
because
the uh compliance with the minsk
agreements ultimately might set a an
obstacle
uh maybe a a a strategic obstacle on
ukraine joining the nato alliance and
this is i
can i think that this is the goal that
putin is trying to accomplish if he is
able to prevent ukraine joining nato
through other means uh then probably he
will demonstrate more flexibility on the
implications of the minsk agreements
michael i can see that you want to jump
in before you do i just also want to ask
you do you think that there are going to
be more normandy format talks going
forward and
even if there were some type of
agreement uh that were reached uh do you
think that president zielinski would
actually be able to push this kind of a
deal through parliament in ukraine
look um i i want to react first of all
to what
what my colleague my russian colleague
said uh very simple uh we don't have
information as to whether or not there
will be an imminent invasion all we know
is that there are 190 000 troops on our
borders and those 190 000 troops are not
exactly defensive most of them are
what's called italian tactical groups
those are attack forces first of all
secondly i read the kremlin website i
listen to what putin says and putin
specifically has said and the website if
you want to in july published his uh
musings on the history of ukraine and
russia and how we are supposedly one
people he has come out many many times
and said that he does not recognize
ukraine's right to exist as a separate
country i am a ukrainian i would like to
exist
i believe that that is leaves us very
little room for negotiation when uh
someone is invading you and says that
you have no rights to exist and you are
defending yourself and you are saying i
have a right to exist what is there to
negotiate about it's very much a to be
or not to be type of scenario um there's
very little to negotiate now yes we are
of course interested in having a
normandy format a u.s format president
zielinski has said that he would be very
happy to bring in president erdogan from
uh from turkey into this into this
situation um he has stated yesterday in
munich that he would love to meet with
putin putin is not interested in meeting
putin is interested in destroying at the
end of the day ukrainians are preparing
to defend themselves there's very little
to talk about at that point when you are
at the at gunpoint that is the reality
at the moment you cave is
uh and i will not say uh evacuating but
certainly very very concerned
particularly after president biden's
statement of the fact that uh putin has
already made his decision we have seen
maps we have seen troops troop buildups
and we have listened to what president
putin has to say and unfortunately none
of that makes us particularly confident
in the prospects for peace
matthew what do you think you think
there's going to be more of these
normandy format talks going forward and
even if there are and even if there is
some type of agreement that is reached
do you think that it will hold
well i don't anticipate a normative
format discussion until the current
extreme high level of tension decreases
and you know what what we're seeing
right now in eastern ukraine is exactly
what we saw in georgia in august 2008
when there supposedly were peacekeepers
on the ground from russia but there were
separatists who opened fire on georgian
uh military positions this is happening
in eastern ukraine as well right now
ukrainian leadership is withholding
counter-strikes the georgian government
did for a while but then it did
retaliate and that prompted a full-scale
russian invasion uh of georgia so i
think this is exactly what president
putin is trying to provoke again he's
talked about a military technological
response if his demands are not met but
not an invasion so what he's going to do
is say well the ukrainians fought back
we didn't invade we were defending that
we were defending against their assault
on on on the separatist troops so until
that clears until that crisis moment
clears uh it's an academic exercise to
talk about more normandy format
discussions and again
russia claims it's not a party to the
minsk agreements then why in the world
would it threaten and threaten an
invasion and to kill tens of thousands
of people civilians
for the implementation of an obscure
agreement to which it claims it is not a
party it just the story does not hold
together but before we can get back to
normandy you got to get past this moment
of high military tension and matthew i
guess one of the concerns would be that
president putin is using the minsk
agreements as a political tool this must
be something that western countries are
are very worried about right
i hope they are i mean in a lot of you
know discussions i listen to and have
been involved with i hear europeans
told try to hold ukraine's feet to the
fire and say you know if if you don't
implement the misc agreements then well
then suggesting perhaps russia has a
justification uh to try to force
implementation and that that's a total
red herring moscow does not care about
the minsk agreement so uh i i hope i
hope that throughout the nato alliance
uh european leaders do recognize
muhammad just what you said uh that that
the minsk agreement really again the
focus on it now is a red herring what
russia is about now is yes as mikhail
said uh destabilizing ukraine preventing
ukraine from ever joining nato and i
stand by what i said before also uh
relitigating the post-cold war security
framework to which russia agreed by the
way it agreed in 1994 in the budapest
memorandum uh to support ukraine's
territorial integrity and sovereignty if
ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons
ukraine lived up to its end of the
bargain russia has violated as deeply as
you could
andre the fact that the minsk agreements
are not legally binding how much does
that complicate this all
well i think that it might open various
avenues for the russian leadership
in donbass for instance given the
current escalation uh i do not exclude a
diplomatic
recognition of the breakaway republics
by russia and that would be of course a
game changer that would indeed make the
situation east ukraine somewhat similar
to what happened in georgia back in 2008
and then i think uh the minsk agreements
will collapse i don't think that the
probability is very high but i do not
exclude that because in my view the
state duma would have never advanced
such an idea if they had not received a
not from the kremlin
so right now i think this is uh probably
a more
likely challenge to the minsk agreements
than
an invasion of russia across the border
with ukraine at least that's how i see
the situation today
and for me uh the
most immediate task is to preserve the
minsk agreements to avoid the diplomatic
recognition of the breakaway republics
and to get back to the negotiating table
i don't think that we have other
plausible options to reach any progress
in the escalating the situation
kylo i'm curious to get your perspective
on one thing
most people say that the minsk
agreements have essentially been a
failure from the outset
have there been any successes that have
come from them
well look there was an attempt to uh to
push through parliament some changes to
uh to to ukraine's constitution uh those
failed
but we do have uh one of the
requirements the political requirements
of the minsk agreement was to provide uh
in parliament a special law that
provided more autonomy for
uh those areas that were that are
currently occupied uh should and but one
of the one of the the uh presumptions of
that law uh for it to go go forward was
for the occupation to end in other words
russian troops leave and then these uh
areas become uh integrated into the rest
of ukraine as autonomous regions uh with
their own police forces with their own
judiciary in other words uh significant
amounts of autonomy those steps were
made however at the end of the day the
military requirements of a full
ceasefire and a withdrawal of russian
troops have never happened and as a
matter of fact what we're seeing now is
a further escalation and further
advancement of of of russian forces onto
ukraine's territorial integrity i do
want to say that um you know
we're all hoping for peace we're all
hoping for some sort of a resolution to
this but at the end of the day uh when
president biden comes out and says that
the decision has been made and that
putin has made his decision and the u.s
intelligence says that the decision to
move in by russian forces has been made
that makes it very very difficult to
even dream about any kind of a peaceful
solution at the moment we're looking for
de-escalation michael you mentioned the
hope for a peaceful solution if there is
a peaceful resolution to all that's
going on right now would there be
any appetite in ukraine for a minsk
based settlement
look uh i'm not sure that it needs to be
minsk based it could be any other choose
another city if you like but the reality
is that yes ukrainians are interested in
a settlement having said that
uh we are interested in also
de-escalation on our borders we are not
interested in having russian troops
amass on our borders constantly secondly
uh the donbass crisis and the fact that
there is an occupation in eastern
ukraine should not be separated from the
fact that there is an illegal annexation
of crimea that has happened and crimea
has officially been now supposedly
transferred to the russian federation
well that's problematic as well so
russia has taken over seven percent of
our territory uh and continues to be
threatening to take more so uh looking
at peaceful solutions of course uh but
at the end of the day i think ukrainians
understand today that the existential
threat that russia presents to ukraine
is long term and we will have to deal
with that long term it's not something
that's going to go away tomorrow uh for
as long as the putin regime remains in
the kremlin
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave our
conversation there thank you so much to
all of our guests andre cortonov
mikhailov vanetsky and matthew bryza
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jim the whole team here bye
for now
[Music]